[Music]
it was the cliffhanger that
captivated the nation and 40 years ago
today on cbs
we learned who done it
[Music]
in the spring of 1980 the third season
of the hit drama dallas
ended with j.r ewing shot by an unknown
assailant
and because jr played by larry hagman
was a character
fans of the show loved to hate just
about
every other cast member had a reason to
see him gone
don't even dream of double-crossing me
captain don't threaten me honey you're
way out of your league
for him to be shot just made him even
more mythic that whole season he'd
gotten worse and worse meaner and meaner
to so many people
anybody could have shot him but the
show's producers had no
idea the cliffhanger would become a
worldwide
phenomenon that summer hagman as j.r
appeared on magazine covers t-shirts
even beer cans
vegas started taking bets even british
royals were intrigued
we were presented to the queen mother
and she says i don't suppose you could
tell me who saw jail
i said no ma'am not even you with such
intense interests producers worried the
killer's identity would leak
so they spent a day filming each cast
member pulling the trigger
adding to the tension an actor strike
that delayed the fall tv season
when the episode titled whodunit finally
aired
83 million americans a then record 76
percent of the tv audience
tuned in for the big reveal i have
finally figured everything out that's
all
you're crazy the shooter was kristin
shepherd jr's conniving sister-in-law
and former mistress
played by actress mary crosby
it's hard to imagine a show drawing that
kind of audience 83 million people to
the tv for one night for one episode
we just don't watch tv the same way we
just don't all come together that way
and i wish we did
now wouldn't that be a scandal and that
was a friday night by the way
friday night in the election that year
85 million people
two million more people voted but that's
it i miss
those kinds oh i know dynasty and knots
landing too
we've never had another one like it just
haven't and i
came to expect them and you just don't
get that same feeling
what happened to her after she shot j.r
she got booted off the series i think
that
and that was sort of the kiss of death
yeah and he he was the man
you don't get the original the original
way was he
uh major i dreamed oh
yeah sorry guys